[Music]  Khloe Kardashian is ready to welcome her  little girl any day now  on Monday the 33 year old took the  snapchat supposed these fun filtered  photos posing in a gray Calvin Klein  sports bra and yep showing off that baby  bump it's just all like weird what's  happening I think of just like you're  growing a human Khloe's really excited  and setting up two nurseries one in  Cleveland and one in Los Angeles so it  was great fun running around picking  stuff out earlier Monday Chloe shared  this sweet shot from a pregnancy photo  shoots with Tristan Thompson quote we  are ready whenever you are little mama  and as she wait for her little one to  arrive mom Kris Jenner told ET of this  on Sunday I give her so much advice  she's sick of me yeah we all give her  advice because you know most of us have  had a child or two in this family so  yeah we're just I mean when you have  your first baby you're scared  [Music]